should the prime minister come clean
about the party were you at the party
sir is the prime minister in trouble
difficult questions to answer in downing
street this morning made all the harder
by leaked video of number 10 staff
joking about a lockdown christmas party
at a mocked up press briefing last year
i went home
hold on hold on um
ah
would the promise to condone uh how are
you
chris
what's the answer
boris johnson says there wasn't a party
but public denials undermined by this
private rehearsal the pm trying to
distance himself from events under his
own roof
and throwing his staff under the bus
i understand
and share the anger
up and down the country at seeing number
10 staff
seeming to make light of lockdown
measures i was also furious to see that
clip
and mr speaker
i apologize
i apologize unreservedly for the offense
that it has caused up and down the
country i have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken and that is what
i have been repeatedly assured
but i've asked
the cabinet secretary
to establish all the facts
the prime minister the government spent
the week telling the british public
there was no party all guidance was
followed completely
millions of people now think the prime
minister was taking them for fools
that they were lied to
they're right aren't they
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but that's little reassurance to his
colleagues look at their faces the prime
minister weakened at a critical moment
her majesty the queen sat alone when she
marked the passing of the man she'd been
married for 73 years
leadership
sacrifice
that's what gives leaders the moral
authority to lead
does the prime minister think he has the
moral authority to lead and to ask the
british people to stick to the rules
a pm caught on the wrong side of public
opinion and his colleagues know it
anyone who says there wasn't a party but
knew about it and said in parliament
there was no party it has misled
parliament and that is a serious charge
and you cannot continue in the highest
office in the land if you've done that
the pm under immense pressure the public
furious and his former spokesperson
broken resigning today in tears the
british people have made immense
sacrifices in the ongoing battle against
copenhagen
i now fear that my comments in the
leaked video of the 20th of december
last year have become a distraction in
that fight
a distraction when boris johnson and his
government need to focus on omicron and
what to do about it doesn't it lead to
your leadership being questioned
if others are taking responsibility for
things that happen in this place instead
of you taking responsibility on your
point about responsibility i don't just
take responsibility for things that
happen in this in this in this building
i take responsibility for everything
that happens in this in this government
and i've made i've made that clear
throughout the pandemic
but some in his party are angry because
they think the prime minister doesn't
take responsibility
and his demeanor in the commons today
showed that he understands the political
danger he's now in
at best this was a bruising day at
whilst it was an inflection point for a
prime minister who was once celebrated
for his popular touch but is now getting
things badly wrong and the timing
couldn't be worse a prime minister whose
authority and credibility is collapsing
at the very moment he asked people to
obey new rules
an embattled prime minister fighting on
so many fronts number 10 in disarray a
public that doesn't believe what he says
and a parliamentary party losing the
faith beth rigby sky news westminster